it's Friday which means it's time for
[Music]
protestors get creative outside Mitch
McConnell's house and sexual politics
are taking over boardrooms and
classrooms for all the details we're
joined by Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor comedian during breaks and
New York Times bestselling author the
wheel Wilder series Raymond tell me
about the early morning protests outside
of McConnell's townhouse imagine it's
7:30 in the morning and you're awakened
by a protest coming up the block you can
imagine Mitch McConnell Elaine what is
that out there and then he saw this
watch now they were walking up the block
saying chug chug chug I like beer this
is like walking into the Pirates of the
Caribbean in old town I mean the poor
man is surrounded by these drunken
protesters this is 7:30 in the morning
and they're gay a paps Red Ribbon beer
wood red Blue Ribbon don't touch this
and they have the Red Solo cups and
they're saying I like beer I like beer
now remember Brett Kavanaugh at his
hearings did mention this hmm
we drank beer my friends and I the boys
and girls yes we drank beer
I liked beer still liked beer we drank
beer we liked beer you see my question
is I don't know what this protest is
about because if you don't like the guy
why are you mimicking his words or do
you support him or not I mean it seemed
like any random morning on frat row it's
what we were doing it didn't look like
much of a protest it looked more like a
collection of disgruntled neighbors just
wanting to wait like a zoning the
grievance with Mitch McConnell or this
was a creative protest compared to what
was going on in the bowels of the
Capitol okay this is an organizer giving
his marchers orders but uh I think
kindergarten you be the judge
[Music]
let's go watch the boat to the offices
you go baby they were going to the wrong
office
what are you going to heidi heitkamp
like wait zombie is it hos dom be she's
on our side
Oh totally totally my bad but why do you
have to have a chant and and echo four
basic orders I only want to go to the
office going we're going to the offices
to the offices the offices okay
the meter movement is getting a pretty
big birthday present in California the
governor signed a bill requiring public
corporations to in his state to have at
least one female director on their
boards by 2021 every board will have to
have three female yeah do you think this
is even constitutional or well I think
Pacific Islanders Latino Americans and
every other group should say what about
me how about I just want men to be on
the all-female boards and then there
might be parody what all-female board
there are narf let me tell you about
this selfie suicide movement that's
happening the Indian Health Services did
a study 259 people in seven years lost
their lives taking these risky selfie
shots mostly men people between ten and
twenty nine but that number is really
low they're saying it's almost 250 it's
much higher than that the all they did
was look at publicly to clear cases
there a lot that went undeclared but
it's people on rooftops on monuments
they're there in traffic and they're
dying
taking the shot in our selves anity okay
before I go uh-oh I thought just to just
to bring it all together Laura
I like whole segments take it selfie
here you take that this hurts and I'll
take a quick sale for you ready ready
okay okay
smile do we have it